labyrinthische dinge die scheinbar ins
nichts führen die keiner bemerkte sie
doch für die britische luftwaffe waren
sie überlebenswichtig
eine geisterstadt mitten in der wüste
das war eine voll ausgestattete
militäranlage bereit für den ernstfall
[Applaus]
gigantische stahl türme aus einer
anderen zeit
stahl veränderte nicht nur die region
sondern die ganze welt er prägte das
zwanzigste jahrhundert
und eine tonnenschwere kanone
zurückgelassen auf einer verschneiten
berg spitze sie hat ihren beitrag zum
sieg italiens geleistet es hat sich
gelohnt sie hierauf zu bringen sie hat
ihre aufgabe erledigt und zwar sehr gut
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sie zählten einmal zu den
fortschrittlichsten bauten der welt mit
das modernste was ingenieurs und
baukunst zu bieten hatten
dann wurden diese bauten aufgegeben
manche sind konnte lebensgefährlich
verseucht
wer hat sie errichtet und wie und warum
wurden sie ausgemustert
[Musik]
im südwesten londons inmitten eines
unscheinbaren industriegeländes steht
ein in die jahre gekommener betonbau
[Musik]
wer würde solche rätselhaften
gerätschaften in riesigen
holzkonstruktionen praktisch mitten in
der stadt vermuten
wirklich erstaunlich
[Musik]
auf den ersten blick ist es ein rätsel
auf der ort
zwei runde öffnungen führen in einen
beton tunnel 70 meter lang 40 meter
breit
die wände sind von rillen und verdeckten
kanälen durchzogen
der tunnel hat keinen ausgang nach einer
reihe von rechten winkeln ist man wieder
zurück am eingang
[Musik]
die ingenieure standen damals vor völlig
neuen problemen die schiere größe der
anlage machte den bau aber auch den
betrieb zu einer echten herausforderung
[Musik]
welchen zweck diente dieser enorme
tunnel mit all seiner komplexen technik
und wenn sein bau so aufwendig war warum
wurde er dann stillgelegt
[Musik]
mai 1933 adolf hitler an nennt den
ehemaligen jagdflieger hermann göring
zum reiss luftfahrtminister
es ist der erste schritt auf dem weg zur
gründung der deutschen luftwaffe im jahr
hitler will deutschland schnell zu einer
der stärksten luftstreitkräfte machen
schon bald arbeitet die deutsche
luftfahrtindustrie mit hochdruck am auf
rüstungsprogramm
einige der weltbesten ingenieure
entwickeln eine ganz neue
flugzeuggeneration
[Musik]
die altmodischen doppeldecker wurden von
modernen maschinen abgelöst die
britische regierung wollte sich auf
keinen fall von den deutschen abhängen
lassen
[Musik]
das weiteres boot mit seinen lauf die
engländer bauen eine topmoderne
forschungseinrichtungen den windkanal in
form bringen
die anlage ermöglicht es den britischen
entwicklern dass ihre dynamische
verhalten von flugzeugen und der
realistischen bedingungen zu testen
[Musik]
günther
in diesem bild kanal spielt beim
entwickeln und testen von flugzeugen
eine entscheidende rolle
die aero dynamischen eigenschaften eines
flugzeugs werden von sämtlichen äußeren
teilen beeinflusst selbst die
radaufhängung und die form der klappen
sind von bedeutung
deshalb muss alles genau getestet werden
selbst kleinste teile können für die
flugleistung einen riesen unterschied
machen
[Musik]
der bau der anlage ist ein mammutprojekt
und das nicht nur wegen seiner größe
jede komponente von den gigantischen
truppen bis zu den verwendeten
baustoffen muss sorgfältig ausgewählt
werden damit eine optimale leistung
garantiert ist
cheftechniker kenny rogers kennt die
gegebenheiten
der bau dauerte vier jahre die
arbeitsbedingungen waren meines
erachtens ziemlich furchterregend
[Musik]
im tunnel musste jedes detail stimmen
die luftströmung musste gleichmäßig sein
kein noch so kleiner bolzen durfte aus
der wand ragen die lüftungsschlitze
mussten perfekt sitzen und durften keine
zusätzlichen turbulenzen verursachen
1935 nimmt der windkanal den betrieb auf
anstatt mit maßstabsgetreuen modell zu
arbeiten werden echte maschinen in den
tunnel gebracht
ihre aerodynamik eigenschaften werden
getestet und wenn nötig korrigiert aber
die uhr läuft gegen die briten die
deutschen prototypen demonstrieren
bereits ihre leistungsfähigkeit und
brechen reihenweise rekorde
1935 pflegt die einmotorige junkers ju
87 auch bekannt als stuka erster
einsätze
wenig später folgt die messerschmitt bf
109 die zum standard jagdflugzeug der
luftwaffe werden sollen
1939 und 1940 spielen beide eine
entscheidende rolle im sogenannten
blitzkrieg mit denen die deutschen
westeuropa überrennen und die briten zum
rückzug über den ärmelkanal zwingen
im lauf des zweiten weltkriegs
entwickelten die deutschen ihre
flugzeuge ständig weiter deshalb war es
für die briten wichtig ihre flugzeuge
ebenso permanent sie verbessern nur so
hatten sie eine chance gegen die nazis
[Musik]
der propeller in der mitte des
windkanals hat einen durchmesser von
zehn metern
er erzeugt eine luftströmung von fast
200 kilometern pro stunde
[Musik]
das mächtige gebläse bringt es auf 250
umdrehungen pro minute es sorgt die luft
an und wirbelt sie mit den flügeln
durcheinander auf dem weg durch die
gänge wird die strömung mit hilfe von
aus richtern und deflektoren geglättet
am ende trifft sie ein zweiter luftstrom
auf das testflugzeug
[Musik]
bei voller kraft drückte die anlage 130
tausend kubikmeter luft durch die gänge
wir hatten die
spitfires landwind eine chance dörling
eine henkel
tests an deutschen maschinen wie der
enkel helfen den briten die eigene
technologie zu verbessern
[Musik]
bis 1940 die luftschlacht um england ist
im vollen gange optimieren die
ingenieure in faro kontinuierlich die
leistung britischer jagdflugzeuge wie
der hocker harry caine und der spitfire
[Musik]
die ersten spitfire modelle am anfang
des zweiten weltkriegs hatten propeller
mit zwei flügeln am ende des krieges
hatten sie verstellbare propeller mit
vier flügeln mit dem sogenannten
verstellt propeller erzielt man eine
deutlich bessere steig leistung
[Musik]
ohne windkanal lässt sich so was nicht
entwickeln
und
die ingenieure forschen weiter sie
wollen der royal airforce helfen den
krieg zu gewinnen
eine verbesserte kühlung und ein
reduzierter luftwiderstand machen die
maschinen wendiger und effektiver mit
der einführung des berühmten lancaster
bomber aus dem jahr 1942 gewinnen die
briten allmählich die oberhand
die britischen flugzeuge wurden immer
besser und die nazis versuchten eine
wundersame superwaffe zu entwickeln die
den krieg für sie gewinnen würde
die deutschen scheiterten weil sie auf
die falsche technologie setzten
[Musik]
die nazis waren die flugzeugtechnik
revolutionieren beispielsweise mit der
einführung des düsen antriebs und so das
ruder noch einmal herumreißen
die alliierten setzen dagegen auf
behutsamen fortschritt und produzieren
lieber die eingeführten modelle in
großer stückzahl
einrichtungen wie der windkanal in faro
helfen den alliierten die lufthoheit zu
gewinnen und sich an schließlich auch
den sieg im zweiten weltkrieg
mit beginn des bösen zeitalters aber
verliert farm bureau an bedeutung und
wird allmählich überflüssig
ein propeller getriebener kanal wurde
plötzlich nicht mehr gebraucht starke
luftströmungen konnte man jetzt auch mit
düsen antrieben erzeugen altmodische
anlagen wie fan büro waren plötzlich
reif für den müllhaufen der geschichte
[Musik]
1992 geht im windkanal endgültig die
puste aus
heute ist er teil eines historischen
luftfahrtmuseums
[Musik]
der einsatz der britischen piloten
während der luftschlacht um england ist
bestens dokumentiert
weniger bekannt ist die arbeit die
anordnung wie von roll geleistet wurde
eine arbeit die es der royal airforce
ermöglichte zu gewinnen
[Musik]
der windkanal im pfarrbüro war ein
ungemein wichtiger bestandteil der
britischen kriegs anstrengungen
die arbeit dort blieb quasi unterm radar
aber ohne sie hätte es keine britische
luftwaffe gegeben
[Musik]
das nächste verlassene objekt führt uns
in die mongolei genauer gesagt in die
wüste gobi wo die gras bewachsene steppe
bis zum horizont reicht
25 kilometer nordwestlich der stadt
steuer erheben sich rätselhafte gebilde
aus den karten wurden
münchen das ist ein gott verlassener ort
am ende der welt
[Musik]
jede der insgesamt 40 erhebungen ist
zehn meter hoch 30 meter lang und an
einer mit unkraut überwucherte
betonpiste angeschlossen
eine etwa drei kilometer lange straße
führt zu einer nahegelegenen hügelkette
am seltsamsten aber sind die lehren
plattenbauten die hier verfallen
wieso wurde in dieser abgelegenen einöde
eine siedlung errichtet und warum wurde
sie verlassen
[Musik]
bald nach dem zweiten weltkrieg sind die
volksrepublik china und die sowjetunion
zunächst enge verbündete
ende der 50er jahre aber führen
ideologische differenzen zu einer
abkühlung der beziehungen
hinzu kommen unterschiedliche
vorstellungen über den umgang mit den
usa
das zerwürfnis mündet in einen
handfesten grenzkonflikt der die beiden
großmächte an den rand eines krieges
bringt
die kommunistischen anführer in russland
und china konnten einander einfach nicht
ausstehen
dabei ging es weniger um kommunismus als
um die frage wer der bessere war
1968 verlegt die sowjetunion massiv
truppen an die chinesische grenze
eingeklemmt zwischen den beiden
kontrahenten ist ein verbündeter der
udssr die mongolische volksrepublik der
sowjetische satellit befindet sich
plötzlich im zentrum eines explosiven
konflikts
die mongolei war schon immer ein
umkämpftes territorium die spannungen
nahmen im lauf der 60er jahre weiter zu
bis zu dem punkt wo aus streitereien
militärische auseinandersetzungen wurden
so wie jetzt erschufen den mongolischen
staat als puffer gegen mögliche
chinesische angriffe
sie fürchteten sich vor china das immer
moderner und stärker wurde
sie fürchteten sich vor einem krieg
die sowjetunion stationiert
hunderttausende soldaten an der
chinesisch mongolischen grenze
schützenhilfe leisten die russischen
luftstreitkräfte
[Musik]
der stützpunkt in variante spielt dabei
eine zentrale rolle
hier ist das 126 jagdflieger regiment
stationiert
die anlage ist brandneu und riesengroß
sie soll im fall eines chinesischen
angriffs als erste verteidigungslinie
dienen
mental ist gigantisch mit drei kilometer
langen landebahnen und massiven bunkern
in denen die flugzeuge selbst heftigste
angriffe überstehen können
etwa 1800 männer mit ihren familien
stationiert sie waren für die flugzeuge
und den reibungslosen ablauf zuständig
das war eine voll ausgestattete
militäranlage bereit für den ernstfall
[Musik]
1970 beginnen die bauarbeiten in der
mongolischen steppe
nur wenig dringt über die einzelheiten
nach außen auch die kosten bleiben ein
geheimnis
[Musik]
das projekt stellt die ingenieure vor
völlig neue herausforderungen
mit den europäischen stützpunkten hat es
nur wenig gemein
eine komplette stadt soll von grund auf
errichtet werden und dafür muss jedes
einzelne teil aus der sowjetunion
angeliefert werden
die sowjets waren richtig gut darin
mitten im nirgendwo riesige bauvorhaben
zu verwirklichen es war ja schon
schwierig genug eine drei kilometer
lange landebahn am stadtrand von moskau
anzulegen aber stellen sie sich vor sie
machen dass am ende der welt tausende
von kilometern entfernt vom nachschub
daran sehen sie wie viel geld und
ressourcen die sowjets für die
landesverteidigung aufbrachten
1972 mit der stützpunkt den betrieb auf
flugabwehrraketen systeme und ein
netzwerk aus verteidigungs bunkern
sichern die stellung
in den bombensicheren hangars warten
dutzende kampfflugzeuge wie die mig 21
und 23 auf ihren einsatz
auf dem stützpunkt gab es eine mig 21
staffel die mig 21 gehörte damals zu den
weltbesten überschall abfangjägern
gegenüber den chinesen diente sie als
abschreckung
sie gehörte zu den zehn großen
flugzeugen des kalten krieges die usa
machten über nordvietnam bekanntschaft
mit ihr wo sie sich als starker gegner
erwies es machte spaß sie zu fliegen sie
war einfach zu warten und absolut
zuverlässig
die technik vom feinsten sein aber das
leben auf dem stützpunkt ist hart im
sommer steigen die temperaturen bis auf
40 grad celsius im winter pfeift ein
eisiger wind über die steppe und das
thermometer fällt auf bis zu minus 40
grad
er gab es viele probleme die maschinen
mussten in den wüsten klima in schuss
gehalten werden und dann war da die
moral der truppe in so einer
unglücklichen gegen war es nicht leicht
die motivation hochzuhalten
während der 70er und 80er jahre lassen
die politischen spannungen nicht nach
variante bleibt in alarmbereitschaft
[Musik]
großen und chinesen haben in dieser
phase ganz unterschiedliche interessen
die
spannungen zwischen moskau und peking
dritten sich natürlich auch auf die
mongolei aus
[Musik]
der luftwaffenstützpunkt in bayenthal
leistet seinen beitrag ernsthafte
kriegerische auseinandersetzungen
zwischen den beiden großmächten zu
verhindern
als michael gorbatschow 1985 die macht
übernimmt leitet er eine phase der
entspannung ein
wenige jahre später kommt es zum
zusammenbruch der sowjetunion
jetzt fehlen die mittel um den
stützpunkt in bayenthal weiter zu
betreiben
[Musik]
die sowjetunion war kein reiches land
sie brach auch deshalb zusammen weil sie
ihr weit verzweigtes netz mit teuren
militärischen anlagen nicht mehr
aufrecht erhalten konnte wie hunderte
andere wurde auch dieser komplex
aufgegeben
im dezember 1989 wird der stützpunkt in
bayenthal geschlossen
[Musik]
heute ist er eine geisterstadt
der stützpunkt ist dem verfall
preisgegeben
die einheimischen kommt zwar manchmal
vorbei wohnen aber nicht in den häusern
da passiert gar nichts mehr
während des kalten krieges dachte
niemand an die mongolei
bayernteil zeigt uns jedoch dass ein
atomkrieg auch in der weiten steppe
hätte losgehen können
wie die meisten militäranlagen erlebte
auch diese nie den ernstfall das heißt
aber nicht dass sie eine sinnlose
investition war wenn sie geholfen hat
einen konflikt zu vermeiden hat sie ihre
aufgabe erfüllt
auf der anderen seite des planeten in
pittsburgh pennsylvania steht das wrack
einer verblüffenden stahlkonstruktion
[Musik]
es ist der ehemalige hochofen carey
firnis der hier knapp ein jahrhundert
lang roheisen produziert
es sieht besser aus wie ein retro
themenpark
es
erinnert uns an die zeit der
industrialisierung mit ihren enormen
anlagen
die fabrik ist so groß dass die
umliegenden gebäude geradezu winzig
erscheinen
[Musik]
2 von ohren ummantelte türme flankieren
den mächtigen schornstein und sechs
raketen förmige sie los
[Musik]
das ensemble ist an eine eisenbahnbrücke
angeschlossen die scheinbare und wohin
führt
[Musik]
besucher konnten kaum fassen wie riesig
die anlage ist all die rohre leitungen
und komplizierten verbindungen das
übersteigt unsere vorstellungskraft
[Musik]
was genau ging in diesem wirrwarr aus
stahl und beton vor sich und warum wurde
der gigantische bau stillgelegt
anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
boomt in den usa die baubranche
was jetzt dringend gebraucht wird stahl
eisen und stahl waren das rückgrat der
amerikanischen industrie jedes gebäude
jede brücke jedes auto jeder zu jedes
schiff sie alle enthielten stahl aus
pittsburgh
[Musik]
im grunde war das américas geburtsstunde
des empire state building die brooklyn
bridge jede stadt errichtete stolze
bauten die nur dank der stahlproduktion
möglich waren
[Musik]
stahlproduktion ist gefährlicher arbeit
und das einschmelzen von eisenerz gehört
dazu
aber es kann nicht genug produziert
werden um den wachsenden hunger der
industrie zu stillen
leitet die rivers of steel national
heritage steria eine stiftung die das
historische erbe pennsylvanias lebendig
hält
der stark veränderte nicht nur den
westen pennsylvanias
sondern die ganze welt er prägte das
zwanzigste jahrhundert
die betreiberfirma us deal will den
lieferengpass beheben und zwar mit
diesen höfen nummer sechs und sieben
die ungewöhnlich hohen türme werden
errichtet um die eisenproduktion zu
steigern
im grunde wurden hier steine und felsen
in einen von menschenhand geschaffenen
vulkan geworfen es gab drei wesentliche
zutaten eisenerz koks und kalkstein
[Musik]
sie wurden bei großer hitze
eingeschmolzen anschließend über den
fluss transportiert und dort zu stahl
verarbeitet
[Musik]
der schmelzofen wird nicht ohne grund
bei pittsburgh errichtet von mir ist es
nicht weit bis zu den steinkohle
vorkommen der appalachen
in dieser gegend gibt es besonders
reichhaltige bodenschätze die kohle
kalkstein und eisenerzvorkommen liegen
gleich unter der oberfläche und genau
die braucht man um reisen zu produzieren
[Musik]
die bauarbeiten beginnen im jahr 1906
die 30 meter hohen brennkammern zu
errichten ist kein kinderspiel
die wände bestehen aus sechs cm dicken
stahlplatten sie sind mit tausenden
mauerziegeln ausgekleidet und halten
temperaturen von bis zu 2000 grad
celsius stand
[Musik]
das material wird im ofen über einen
schrägaufzug mit kleinen schritt waggons
zum geführt dieser prozess wird als
beschickung bezeichnet
[Musik]
stellen sie sich den ofen als
reagenzglas vor darunter steht ein
bunsenbrenner mit dem wir die stoffe
erhitzen
damit das eisen vom gestein getrennt
wird muss es mit dem koks reagieren
außerdem fügen wir kalzium hinzu um die
sogenannten silika tischen gesteine
loszulösen
von unten wird vorgewärmte luft
eingeblasen die nach oben steigt während
das material herab sinkt dabei wird es
erhitzt das flüssige reisen bildet sich
ganz unten und läuft heraus
1907 hochofen in betrieb der abstieg des
reisens bei denen die glühende
flüssigkeit mit speziellen waggons
aufgefangen wird ist harte und
gefährliche arbeit
und nichts für schwache nerven
hier haben wir das abstich loch
und das ist der bohrer
das eisen fließt durch das loch dann
durch diese rinne und durch ein loch im
boden genau unter dem noch steht
hoffentlich ein fahnen oder torpedo
wagen bereit
es gab todesfälle und viele verletzte
wer anfang des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
an solchen orten arbeitete war mit 40
ein alter mann der job macht er einen
fertig
[Musik]
die öfen sechs und sieben sind ein
phänomenaler erfolg sie produzieren
mehrere tausend tonnen roheisen pro tag
1910 kommen 60 prozent der
us-amerikanischen stahlproduktion aus
pittsburgh
kerners ist dank seines direkten drücken
anschlusses ungemein effizient
so wird das roheisen auf schnellstem
wege zum benachbarten stahlwerk
transportiert was sich in zeiten großer
nachfrage als besonders nützlich erweist
während des zweiten weltkriegs werden
180 tonnen geschmolzenes roheisen über
die brücke gebracht pro stunde
als im zweiten weltkrieg wurde in dieser
anlage mehr stahl produziert als in ganz
großbritannien die pittsburgh region
produzierte mehr als alle achsen möchte
zusammengenommen
diese gegend hieß nicht umsonst das
arsenal der demokratie hier schlug das
herz der amerikanischen industrie
aber nur wenige jahrzehnte später ist
der produktionsprozess veraltet
es ist unglaublich gefährlich der druck
die hitze die gase die arbeit ist dann
fortwährend der balance akt
wenn der druck in den behältern zu groß
wird können sie explodieren teamwork ist
ganz wichtig jeder muss wissen was er zu
tun hat und sich darüber im klaren sein
dass er versucht einen vulkan zu
bändigen
im lauf der 70er jahre geht die
nachfrage zurück
und immer öfter wird jetzt auch über die
arbeitsbedingungen in den hochofen
diskutiert
wir reden hier über schwerindustrie und
für die männer war es als ob sie in der
hölle arbeitet diese hitze dieser dreck
diese dämpfe und dann dieser
unglaubliche druck unter dem sie die
ganze zeit statt
rund um die uhr bestand die gefahr sich
zu verletzen oder gar ums leben zu
kommen
hohe temperaturen giftige dämpfe
gefährliche arbeit die einem alles
abverlangte das war nur etwas für sehr
harter und einsatzbereite leute
1978 völlig das vorjahr beiden
gigantischen öfen für immer
das herz der industrie schlägt nun
anderswo
[Musik]
die übrigen stahlbauten in der umgebung
gelten als gefährlich und kontaminiert
sie werden abgerissen
[Musik]
die öffnung nummer sechs und sieben
bleiben dagegen erhalten
2006 werden sie als nationale
kulturdenkmäler eingestuft und sind
inzwischen eine touristenattraktion
[Musik]
die 1907 weil das hier modernste technik
orte wie dieser schufen in den usa die
grundlage für den wirtschaftlichen
erfolg des zwanzigsten jahrhunderts
[Musik]
auf der anderen seite des atlantiks die
italienischen alpen die cresta della
croce ist ein gipfel in der ada melo
gruppe einer mehr als 3000 meter hohen
berg massiv
in schwindelerregender höhe steht dort
ein schweres geschütz aus den ersten
weltkrieg über
5000 kilogramm schwer und mit vier meter
langen rohr
[Musik]
etwas so schwer es soweit darauf zu
schleppen beweist einmal mehr wo ein
wille ist ist auch ein weg
[Musik]
wozu die kanone gebraucht wurde versteht
sich von selbst
die frage ist ihr warum sie gerade auf
diesen karten werken versteht
wenn ich in den italienischen alpen auf
so eine kanone stoßen würde wäre ich
ganz schön perplex wie ist sie da
hingekommen
und wieso steht sie immer noch da
1882 schließt das königreich italien
gemeinsam mit dem deutschen reich und
österreich-ungarn den sogenannten
dreierbund
trotzdem kämpft es ab 1915 in einer
allianz mit frankreich russland und den
vereinigten königreich gegen den
nachbarn im norden die österreichisch
ungarische monarchie
ein krieg voller stacheldraht
maschinengewehre und schwerer artillerie
und er wird vor allem an der nordgrenze
ausgetragen in den alpen
österreich und frankreich hatten schon
lange starken einfluss auf italien
ausgeübt
während des ersten weltkriegs sahen die
italiener ihre junge nation durch
österreichische angriffe in den alpen
bedroht und die mussten sie abwehren
1916 besteht die gefahr dass
österreichische truppen in der nähe der
christchurch die italienischen
stellungen durchbrechen und die grenze
überschreiten
[Musik]
das artilleriegeschütz zählt damals zu
den mächtigsten waffen von seinem
einsatz hängt der erfolg der
italienischen verteidigung ab
ohne schwere artillerie oben in den
bergen war ein erfolg gegen österreich
nicht denkbar
[Applaus]
in den bergen genügend ein oder zwei
geschütze und das terrain zu
kontrollieren
die italienische armee aber hat kaum
moderne waffen die einzige lösung ist
ein
149 millimeter geschütz aus dem späten
neunzehnten jahrhundert
die kanone mit dem spitznamen hypoport
da muss also mit pferd skis 30 kilo
schwere granaten bis zu 9000 meter weit
[Musik]
neuere geschütze kommen deutlich weiter
aber die italiener müssen sich mit dem
begnügen was sie haben
[Musik]
wer feuerschutz brauchte wollte keine
kleinen gebirgs geschütze die sich auf
dem rücken eines esels transportieren
ließen die hatte jeder mann brauchte
schwere artillerie
[Musik]
am 9 februar
1916 wird die hypo potter muss ins tal
unterhalb der christa della croce
gebracht
vor ihr liegt der beschwerliche aufstieg
zum tonale pass
sollten die österreicher dieses gebiet
einnehmen wäre der weg nach mailand frei
das geschütz muss so postiert werden
dass es die österreichische offensive in
empfang nehmen kann
straßen gibt es hier nicht und so bleibt
den soldaten nichts anderes übrig als
die tonnenschwere kann ohne den
schneebedeckten berg hinauf zu schleppen
[Musik]
als ingenieur und amateur bergsteiger
kann ich mir kaum vorstellen wie man auf
so eine idee kommen konnte das wetter
der schnee es ist unfassbar was diese
männer durchmachen muss
[Musik]
profi bergsteiger kein olsen startet der
kanone einen besuch ab um besser zu
verstehen wie es den soldaten damals
ergangen ist
sich vorzustellen wie hunderte 18 oder
19 jährige dieses ding hier hoch tragen
aus sicht eines bergsteigers ist das
unglaublich
zu fördern
[Musik]
die soldaten haben nicht nur mit der
eisigen kälte zu kämpfen während des
zermürbenden aufstiegs werden sie
zweimal von lawinen überrollt einige der
männer kommen dabei ums leben
die überlebenden erhalten befehl das
geschütz auszugraben und den aufstieg
fortzusetzen
schnee kann unterschiedliche
eigenschaften haben trockner schnee ist
etwa so wie sand stellen sie sich also
vor das geschütz über eine düne zu
schleppen feuchter schnee ist dagegen
eher wie schlamm
[Musik]
als untergrund zum tragen schwerer dinge
sind beide ungeeignet
[Musik]
nach geschlagenen 78 tagen ist das ziel
endlich erreicht
doch die ursprünglich geplante position
erweist sich als problematisch
[Musik]
ja
die österreichischen stellungen waren da
drüben
in china auf mehr von hier aus war das
zu weit weg
deshalb musste das geschützt zur christa
della croce gebracht werden
das war nah genug dran
und es gab noch ein weiteres problem für
die italienischen truppen
[Musik]
die kanone hatte keine rücklauf bremsen
bei jedem schuss wurde sie nach hinten
geschleudert
dagegen konnte man nichts tun außer den
schwung abzubremsen
dafür würden sogenannte auflauf teile
verwendet sie bremsten den rückstoß und
anschließend rollte die kanone zurück in
die ausgangsposition
ohne die keile wäre die kanone
vermutlich in die tiefe gestürzt
der aufwand macht sich bezahlt mit so
heftigen beschuss haben die österreicher
nicht gerechnet ihre eigene artillerie
hat dem nichts entgegenzusetzen
die gewaltigen granaten der hypo futter
muss pulverisieren die österreichische
abwehr der vormarsch ist gestört und
nicht nur das ab sofort gibt das
geschützt den vorrückenden italienern
feuerschutz
während des ersten weltkriegs gab es auf
so einer höhe keine andere waffe dieses
kalibers
österreich hatte nichts dergleichen
obwohl sie in technischer hinsicht
längst überholt war war sie immer noch
größer als alles andere sie belegte den
feind mit dauerfeuer
[Musik]
zwei jahre lang wog die schlacht über
den wolken hin und her
[Musik]
beide seiten lieferten sich einen
erbitterten kampf die kanone auf der
berg verschaffte den italienern einen
klaren vorteil
1918 setzen die italienischen truppen
zum entscheidenden angriff an
unterstützt vom hypo potter muss
geschützt zwingen sie die österreicher
zum endgültigen rückzug
am ende des krieges wird die nutzlos
gewordene kanone einfach auf dem berg
zurückgelassen
[Musik]
heute werden die übrig gebliebenen
geschütze aus dem ersten weltkrieg in
den museen der welt begutachtet
die kanone von der christa della croce
steht aber immer noch da wo sie ihren
letzten schuss abgab
sie hat ihren beitrag zum italienischen
sieg geleistet es hat sich gelohnt sie
hierauf zu bringen auch wenn sie
eigentlich schon überholt war sie hat
ihre aufgabe sehr gut erledigt
das geschütz auf der christa della croce
zeigt dass eine kriegsentscheidende
waffe nicht unbedingt topmodernen sein
muss sie muss nur zur richtigen zeit am
richtigen ort sein
[Musik]
sie zählten zum fortschrittlichsten was
ingenieurs und baukunst zu bieten hatten
heute sind sie nur noch ein echo der
geschichte sie sind überbleibsel von
krieg und terror aber auch von den
großen erfolgen der forschung und des
menschlichen strebens
[Musik]